What if one day you turn on the news
channel to see this volcanic eruption
already caused 2 million casualties.
Airports are closed.
If all the volcanoes on
earth erupted at once.
What our planet survive all the Ash
Multan, Lafa and scorching gasses.
How far up into the
atmosphere with the ash go?
Would there be anyone left to
report the news? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if all
the earth's volcanoes erupted at once.
Not all volcanoes would pose a danger,
extinct volcanoes.
Those that have interrupted in the last
10,000 years just don't have any magma
left to her up again.
However, at any given time,
there are 10 to 20 volcanoes erupting
somewhere on earth. In total,
there are 1500 active volcanoes on land
and an unknown number of them underwater.
What if all of them are updated at once?
What would this apocalypse
look like exactly?
If all active volcanoes on
earth went off at the same time,
there would be a lot of explosions.
Explosive eruptions would
churn out walls of rocks,
ash and gas wiping out the nearby areas.
You wouldn't be able to outdrive that
giant hot cloud rocks is hot as 1000
degrees would be traveling faster
than 700 kilometers an hour,
but not all volcanoes would are up
that powerfully instead of violently
expelling magma. Some volcanoes would
steadily ejected onto the ground.
That's called an effusive eruption.
If your local volcano erupted that way,
consider yourself lucky,
but not for too long.
Other eruptions would be sending
plumes of ash up into the air.
These would travel for
thousands of kilometers and
cover the earth with a thick
blanket of ash.
Ashy clouds would block the sunlight
plunging the whole planet in the complete
darkness. Without sunlight, there's
no chance of photosynthesis.
All the plants would die, including all
the crops that feed us and the animals
because volcanic ash is
actually tiny rock particles.
It would be very heavy if enough
ash where to fall on your roof,
your home would collapse and you're
not escaping this in an airplane.
The hot clouds of ash would
melt car and plane engines,
I'll flights would be cancelled
anyway because of the low visibility.
Deep Ocean volcanoes make the water
acidic in this kind of environment. See,
life would suffer huge losses.
The entire food chain would be devastated
because no sun rays would reach the
earth surface.
The planet would significantly cooled
down to the point where we might end up in
a new ice age. In the longterm, though,
the global temperatures would change
again this time getting much hotter with
all the carbon dioxide
released during the eruptions,
we'd see a tremendous greenhouse effect
that would start roasting the planet.
Now, if you survived the
volcanic explosions and didn't
die from breathing in the
ash,
the safest place for you and might be on
a ship in the middle of the ocean or in
an underground bunker,
just make sure you have enough food,
supplies and warm clothes
to keep you alive.
In this post apocalyptic
world before coming out,
you'll need to wait until the atmosphere
clears up. That's going to take a very,
very long time and you wouldn't be
seeing the earth you once knew prolonged
volcanic eruptions,
spewing from the planets mental would
dump this partly molten layer on the
surface, causing a mass imbalance. As
a result, our planet might tip over,
just like Mars did about three
and a half billion years ago.
Paris might end up on the North
Pole. Of course, as always,
such a scenario was very
unlikely to happen. At least.
There's no evidence of all volcanoes
erupting at once in the 4 billion year
history of earth. But is it better
to be prepared for everything.